I like your tattoos what are those
numbers on your arm oh that's the day my
dad died he was a fireman died in a fire
17 years ago oh my god I'm so sorry
don't be it's fine he's there you can't
focus on Scott anymore honey he's 24
years old Marjorie let that [ __ ] bird
fly please don't worry mom you know your
daughter got smart and went to college
in a band but I'm still here I'm gonna
be here forever yeah I want to become a
real tattoo artist your work is mad and
consist them Obama a right I love your
tattoo is this is my favorite I've been
dating someone for a little while on
them the first guy you date in 17 years
as a fireman just like that you don't
think that's weird
you're gonna have to pull your weight a
little more around here maybe help ray
get his kids to school Kelly do you know
him he's a new friend
you okay you know you could tell me okay
I trained her in the car she's not gonna
break you ever think about putting on
the jacket why would you even ask me
that it's fun being a fireman it's fine
if you don't have kids
cuz you don't know if you're gonna come
home and not and then your kids are
[ __ ] up you make everyone around you
feel crazy people are normal then they
hang out with you and then that [ __ ]
Jack Nichols and in this round me rock
pool you like [ __ ] H beat off let me
tell you something your dad was a hero
and heroes are necessary and they should
be allowed to have families
you got to get your [ __ ] together the
time is passing by very quickly why do
you think I smoke weed all the time so I
could slow it down
there's like everybody's always
disappointed in me and I never live up
to anybody's expectations hey thanks for
listening all of us in one of the few
people who treat me you know like a
person here welcome
[Music]
you